but I'm here to let everybody know that
I learned my lesson and I will not
fumble another bag yeah but the problem
is we're told as women that we are young
forever and over a certain age you don't
get another bag what up guys welcome to
the just parley things YouTube channel
and welcome to my reaction series before
I start make sure you like the video on
your way in and subscribe to the channel
also we have a brand new merch line so
make sure you go look at that now we
have whale merch women shouldn't boat
shirts all this different stuff okay so
today I am reacting to my biggest regret
is a guy I rejected when he asked me to
settle down with him you guys love
hearing about women's regret don't you
okay let me pull it up there's a guy I
kind of wish I hadn't let go of that's a
bit of a regret um he wanted to settle
down and I didn't and he did settle down
and I did have a family and I'm super
happy for him because I think he found
the right woman and he and he's living
his best life you probably they always
do
they always do let me tell you guys let
me tell you those men we reject they
always do they always do chances are you
have been here before the chaos in the
markets oil and stocks just when you
thought it was safe and interest rates
were Rising new threats come out of
nowhere tensions are boiling from Asia
to Europe and adaptation is the key here
to safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you need some insurance Noble gold
investment has been protecting investors
from disaster for years with precious
metals so if you're worried it might be
time to take a fresh look at gold and
silver gold is a proven Safe Haven
shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3 o Silver America
virtue coin with its new IAS this month
if you open up your Noble gold
Investments Ira or 401K rollover you can
claim your coin today remember crisis
crws portfolios waiver and gold insulate
secure yourself against all threats go
to noblegold investments.com now that's
noblegold investments.com the only gold
company that I
trust recently I mean I was dating
someone for 2 months and they were the
perfect person every way but I there was
I couldn't was he kind to you he was
incred he is the most incredible guy
everything was perfect and I like was
like I was like what is wrong with
myself yeah what is wrong with I well he
yeah ladies we get bored and we leave
and our friends come around and they say
oh just go just go boosted my
self-esteem and my well-being so much
that I thought that I could do better
than him when you get the opportunity to
date such a man do not I think we should
do apology classes Now ladies I'd like
to say a lot of this the this is not
going to work on the men a lot of them
are sick of our [__] but you know you
could you could go back you could say
Sir well let's call him let's call him
Jared that sounds like a nice guy named
Jared Jared Jared Jared you know you
were a good man I should not have let
you go I was selfish and I messed up I'd
like to make it up to you uh would that
work let me know let me know guys
no go but I'm here to let everybody know
that I learned my lesson and I will not
fumble another bag some mistakes you
ain't gonna come back from it's GNA take
you years if you even come back you got
a good man he cares about you he's
listening he's all cleaning up he's
talking to you he's inspiring you you
have some disagreements every now and
then but he's showing up fixing things
and really there for you and you blow
that grass is always greener on the
other side that's how women think it's
not until they get to the other side and
they realize that the grass is yeah they
we like oh no no Brown and the streets
are cold that they realize in this video
we have a woman who rejected a good man
decades ago but she still regrets her
decision most modern women we see making
videos complaining that they can't find
a good man already had the opportunity
to secure him but as always they thought
they could do better but in the end
regret is what is left recently I mean I
was dating someone for 2 months and they
were the perfect person everyway but I
there was I couldn't the mutual
attractiveness just wasn't there and so
it didn't work was he not physically
attractive I think no I think he's a
handsome guy maybe I should say
chemistry for us that it it wasn't a
wretched chemistry The Wretched
chemistry what does that even mean don't
nobody understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth man chemistry
what is the okay that basically means
men don't understand this women
understand this you can find a guy
attractive but not be attracted to him
she's talking about looks um but
sometimes it's not I guess looks alone
because there's sometimes guys that you
find attractive but it's like the way
that's why a lot of times beta Alpha
doesn't have much to do with money if I
had had to guess this guy probably had
the mindset where he put her on a
pedestal a bit and women we just don't
respond well to that I'm starting to
notice that chemistry what is the spark
I don't know but what I've learned is
that you need it I wish it was to my
chagrin that the the spark didn't go off
but yeah cuz my next question would be
how has it worked out with the men
you've had Sparks with cuz typically the
men that we feel like Sparks with they
get a lot of chicks they have Sparks
with a lot of women you know they've
learned how to make make
sparks should be
[Music]
it is just I think it's that thing that
makes you just that draws you to that
person initially and so was he kind to
you he was incred he is the most
incredible guy everything was perfect
and I like was like I was like what is
wrong with myself yeah what is wrong
with I don't I you ask all my friends I
was
translation he wasn't a bad boy but I am
happy that he is free and possibly
dating another woman who will value and
appreciate what he has to give the funny
part is that the guys who give the type
of chemistry she is talking about are
Chads and Ty yeah yep mhm and we all
know what they do when it comes to
relationships therefore give it a few
years and she will be back into the
eting scen as a single mother looking
for the same man she
rejected let's check the comments of
this
video experienced divorce lawyer here
that guy dodged a bullet can you imagine
if she married him then a few years
later wasn't feeling it I see it happen
every day stay safe that spark is the
bad boy treating her like trash he
wasn't toxic enough AKA he was 2 nice
and too predictable and you were bored
yeah that'll do it wow she sits there
and says he is perfect but that was
still not enough proof that a woman will
never be happy with what she has and
that's the problem we think that men are
meant to entertain us and and this is
something I I guess in my life that
maybe has come to like my detriment and
like a PL I don't know I guess a plus
but a lot of times women get bored
because they have no other Hobbies
nothing going on and I don't mean
nothing going on on like you need to
have a highflying career or whatever but
you know I I think it's important as
people that we're always working to
improve at something so we don't get
bored you know whether it's being a
better mother a better sister a better
wife but so many times women just they
think the grass is greener on the other
side and a lot of times it's not and I I
see it all the time I see women on my
show I've interviewed over a thousand
people about this type of stuff you hear
a lot of stories I can't even count the
amount of like women not even just women
like their mother who left their dads
their dads remarry a lot of times the
moms don't he was a safe bit too safe
didn't give her the fluttery feelings
like the bad boys do that's not
chemistry that's called
anxiety you don't need it what is
something that you regret there's a guy
I kind of wish I hadn't let go of that's
a bit of a regret um he wanted to settle
down and I didn't I wasn't ready to um
we were still quite young and he did
settle down and I did have a family and
I'm super happy for him because I think
he found the right woman and and he's
living his best life but I really like
this guy and I still kind of like this
guy I do see him on Facebook and I I
wish him well but there's just a tiny
part of me that thinks huh how would
that have worked out if we stayed
together and it's interesting cuz that's
the same woman in a different body like
20 years later I I mean 40 whatever
she's old but it's interesting when you
start interviewing people because you
you start to see like the same
characters kind of just I don't want to
say reborn but like at different stages
of their lives and you can typically
predict how their lives work out for
them this is what happens when you think
that you can always do better than the
person you are with you can see the pain
of regret in her voice it's sad based on
her own words he wanted to settle down
but she thought that she could get a
better deal she thought that there was a
better option a prince charming
somewhere waiting for her therefore it
wasn't a good idea to settle with him
but she was wrong because after decades
she still regrets her decision as she
wasn't able to replace him she couldn't
find another person better than him and
this is why I think that the small
number of women watching this type of
content are the lucky ones because they
will see real life examples of what life
is really about and it will help them to
make better decisions if a good man
crosses your path make sure that you
keep him don't threw him away like she
did let's jump into the comments section
and so many times if we discarded or if
men discarded women the way that women
can so easily discard men I don't think
that we would have the same attitude in
all honesty I think we would have a lot
of resentment most women don't want a
man that loves her she wants a man that
she loves and the man that she loves he
loves
himself they are so used to Pooky and
Ray Rave that a good relationship seems
like a scam you don't know what you have
until it's gone my life improved 110%
after my ex decided to leave after her
life collapsed we actually get along
better due to her seeing reality yeah so
many women live in delusion God they
think they're so much more important to
their household than they are men run
the household and women never count the
favors that men do for us but we always
count the favors we do for them what
have you done for me lately I gave a
whole lot of love to the wrong person
been single for over a year now and
she's still trying to come back nope I'm
straight she lost a good one example of
making permanent decisions because of
temporary
feeling I can't be the only one with
this kind of story about 2 years ago I
was in a relationship with a man and he
was about 40 I was about what
25 27 something like that but he was
willing to invest in me
physically finan Mally emotionally
religiously like all aspects he wanted
to make me a better woman for him well
he boosted my self-esteem and my
well-being so much that I thought that I
could do better than him damn it
ladies come on and now fast forward I am
now post dealing with a narcissist I Now
understand that not all men have your
best intention at heart Not all men will
invest in you and not all men will
uplift you so when you get the
opportunity to date such a man to not
let it go but I just kind of want to hit
on that topic again uh basically I
fumbled a bag I fumbled a bag with a man
who was willing to invest in me with a
man who was willing to do everything
right by his woman yes I was 27 and he
was more like 38 I mean he it wasn't
that big of a age difference but the
purpose of that video was just to help
women realize that when you have someone
in your corner that is willing to invest
in you and willing to love you the way
that they're supposed to do not think
that that is normal that is a blessing
and from the comments I think we as
women need to work on ourselves because
there was too many hurt men in my
comments but I'm here to let everybody
know that I learned my lesson and I will
not fumble another bag yeah but the
problem is we're told as women that that
we are young forever and over a certain
age you don't get another bag you don't
really get that opportunity housewife is
off the table that's why Kevin Samuels
would say over the age of say 27 28
housewife is off the table well it's too
late now yeah um you either cash out
early or you work for a lifetime she
misses what he used to do for her but
she doesn't miss him but in most cases
even when you do everything to make your
woman happy she still can find a way to
mess it up and threw it out of the
window
and this is another reason you guys
shouldn't make them the main source of
your happiness because it can go bad at
any time no matter what you
do but I like the fact that she wants to
help other
women thanks for watching yeah let me
let me hit the Subscribe button look at
that subscribe this is modern dating
here have very good compilation yeah
guys and I think a lot of times people
take what I say as attacking women and
it's not attacking women but rather I
think we can learn from older women's
mistakes not what they say because older
women will really in my experience tell
you the exact opposite of what you
should do because they're competing with
you even married ones a lot of the time
but what I do think is important is that
we take these things as lessons and we
don't humble a good thing so guys let me
know what you think in the comments make
sure you like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next
time